who needs a new phone he does what do
you got what do you got the
iphone 7
i've got an iphone i got a blackberry
right
you know gangsters use blackberries yeah
the guys who said real gangsters
it's all cracked out and [ __ ] well hey
listen i was thinking about writing my
bar and my diss track on a blackberry
why oh drink because yeah you used to
write on black on blackberry i'm trying
to end channels
like like gangsters and cartels use uh
blackberries
because there's no cloud it's hard to
trace ooh
the bbms yep yeah you sitting there out
yeah well yeah what how do you oh and
they still they still use the
flip phones the little they use the flip
phones too a lot of gangsters
dana white still uses a flip phone he
doesn't have an iphone he has a razor
really yep
are you adding him as a thug a corporate
thug
corporate thug
[Laughter]
thug okay okay i mean i mean i get it
when you get to a certain status it's
like
you can't just trust just having an
iphone like that i get it
yeah but that's why that's why people
love iphones because the security is so
good
so you know like let's say
we didn't know this but chin was a
serial killer and they
like how we always call check i know i
know something's going on
let's say he was killing [ __ ] on the
weekends
and they found his uh phone yeah they
like iphone won't let them
uh crack into the phone like it's
completely against
really like they won't do it for anyone
like they've caught isis guys with
iphones they don't crack into their
phones
like they refuse to like bend and like
break security
what and and that's how crazy their
security is like
our like fbi and dda can't get into the
phones
so yeah so when so when we facetime
right like say you remember like you
have your laptop
and you have recorded you know that
green little circle they said fbi agents
looking
they look at those yeah but that's not
that's not that's not iphone your iphone
like security
yeah that's the cameras and [ __ ] they
say they can see all that [ __ ] like if
you have like cameras in your house like
if you don't have like a strong passcode
people can watch it mm-hmm
you can see these these big nuts
swinging around the house like what
you're going to watch man
i know right yeah this big dick get out
of the house
brandon you
i didn't know they did that though yeah
they can they can so wait like if you're
on facetime on your computer or
something they can well they say like
they the
they can listen they can listen and
record stuff like from the camera
that's why a lot of people like what's
his name eric snowden
snowden always like doesn't have that
[ __ ] in his house you know and you don't
have one in his house
like he doesn't have like on his laptop
he always covers the camera like he
blocks it dad dude
my dad has a duct tape around me like
that was it alexa
my girl's dad got us that like three
christmas girl i'm like we ain't having
that in the house
because people can they they pick up on
it and they what you ask for and like
what you say to it it goes to a database
well hold on it doesn't they can listen
to your conversations it does that on
the iphone because you have a yeah but
you can do it on the iphone 2.
siri yeah bro you ever have a
conversation on your phone i remember i
was talking to my friends i mean i want
these jordans
yes so they was like hold on i went to
the land rover dealer
to look at [ __ ] i don't know how they
made me location
and then when i got home i was just on
my on like my youtube and it's popping
up videos of the car i was looking at
what yeah like just try bringing out his
foot defender
110 videos i'm like what how the [ __ ] do
they know
yeah but it must be because of location
on your maps
and then they just always that land
rover but now they know
too much too much there are a bunch of
tick tock videos about that where
girls will like take their boyfriend's
phone and say engagement ring engagement
ring
engagement ring or what they want
on their phone yeah that's
really smart so then that's
yeah so all their feed will be like
tiffany and company
[Music]
that's so funny shouts out to those
ladies man shout out to them
put a ring on it come on now ariana
grande got engaged
no no her current boyfriend who really
real estate guy i think he likes lit
into her dms during an ig live he said
she was cute and they just started
dating during quarantine right what did
he look like
and that who is this i think she has to
type like
skinny like kind of blinky
um white guys remember remember
judging the way this dude looked they
all look like they just got out of rehab
they all look like they're just got an
aaa she does look happy
they look they look like brother and
sister they look identical first of all
oh my god yeah
they look like and sister wow yeah she
does kind of look like yeah
she's see now now this is why she has
weights she's got tattoos on her hands
she has a lot of tattoos are you serious
she just covers up a lot
small ones she has a lot of little
tattoos but then when she wears
um pretty small clothes she's usually
covered up she's wearing like a sweater
and then
that's a problem she has a lot of
tattoos
he makes a lot of money he's a realist
him i don't know if he makes a lot of
money but he does real estate in l.a got
an idea she makes a ton of money damn
shooters yeah she makes so much money
she's yeah he has a private instagram i
actually tried to lurk on him yesterday
when i found out
okay look at that i just wanted who
she was engaged are you going home cat
for uh no i'm staying here
you're gonna stay here yeah oh damn it's
gonna be um are your family coming here
no everyone's too afraid of covet my
grandparents are at risk right now and
so everyone's just kind of chilling out
what are you doing chin uh pretty much
hanging out with my girlfriend
just on christmas day because you're
right and i'm also moving my stuff too
oh you oh chin moving mm-hmm moving on
guys alex you're staying here i'll see
your fans they're here
everyone's out here um my birthday is on
wednesday so we all just gonna oh [ __ ]
and uh we got a show on wednesday too
yup we got something set up for you
oh i was like we gotta do it oh is it
princess pizza
wait hold on it's not chill day though
no this is not my day
we're putting together a mini birthday
party for you here okay
birthday party yeah for your desk i'm
from my disc okay so who's all coming in
uh
if you want to just see that footage so
you have artwork for you i'll try yeah
i got all work i i don't think he
responds now he'll respond a lot of
people are tagging a lot of people
you know what the problem is is eminem
dropped his kind of thing
right there here we go right here look
at this just drop
the streets on there i had to get the
wrong hilarious
who is that this big sean's big shine
right there he posts that picture
he posted yeah oh that is big chunks
super
this white guy or mexican but you better
go in bro
now the track is pretty much finished so
funny the fans are ryan
bro they tagged me in every big shine
post and they was like yo give it up
mally's going to kill you on the 23rd
i'm not here to be honest you did pretty
well against dumbfounded i thought
it was going to be a nightmare he wasn't
ready at all
so i'll give him ben for the doubt
that's the thing when i booked him i
don't think he was
gonna prepare himself to rap by any
means like maybe talk about it a little
bit about it like
he was like all night writing i know
yeah you caught him out i
[Applause]
listen i gave him something to rebuttal
and he came with the rolex and the
cortez
[Laughter]
british
please don't stop wait wait everyone's
wrong
dumbfound's like damn dog you get it
i love the reactions of what y'all face
is when i started rapping i didn't see
it i just saw the video clip
and bring it goes i thought it was about
to be horrible
and i thought dumbfound was gonna light
you the [ __ ] up yeah but he was like
yeah whatever you said you went down his
little vortex his portal of jesus
is such a beast okay because i'm not a
big uh freestyle
rap fan uh dis fan i love that i love
that i'm not in that world
yeah i'm not in that world but then i
went down the dumbfounded uh world
god damn is he good good gonna kill me
he's gone really really good
yeah if he knew dude you need to kill
him and i wish he prepared to let him
know
that i've been so fun if he just lit you
the [ __ ] up well here's the thing
brennan
uh the next guest should always know
come prepared for what you're good at
you know because i'm studying dude the
next time we have a rap battle guy on
yeah he better be ready he's gonna be
ready he's gonna i bet he's gonna be i
don't know if we'll ever have another
rabbit
we might just i'll have to look at views
but we'll see
yeah yeah honestly i was like who who
come
here i don't know oh but he conceded
right he's a good kid from wyoming
i don't know we can get conceived he was
great yeah i'm yeah he dude he's like
big sean heights i already got small
he's he's ready for you whoo yeah he
would come in ready
dumbfounded's like retired basically
yeah he's like chillin trying to do
other
nah cassidy's retires what he he's um
what on wild enough they get that but
he's free he lights him up on there yeah
he's saying like ej
cut the beat when he do that he lights
up everybody knows
everybody have you guys been watching uh
love island season six
how far are you in season six i thought
we were saving that for the road uh
should i well how far are you
i know i start doing it
me too i can't get enough of it how far
are you in season six
uh damn what episode am i on a new new
girl just came up so the twin
got booted thank you for that
one of them can't tell you which twin it
is better i guess it doesn't matter yeah
and then a new girl so you're probably
you're like at least probably 15
episodes then no
or 11 or 12. i'm on episode 35 of season
five you knee-deep oh you're deep oh
it's so good
so crazy that's 50 episodes it's not
and so that's how big it is in [ __ ]
england
it's so big reality stars don't get that
big out here dude they used to when it
was like flavor
love or but there were there's not any
reality
social media like you go to these cats
social media well but definitely
one million yeah but yeah but but even
even then
some of the i see some people even as
yeah i see some people
complain say after season two they just
booked like instagram
thoughts and dudes that have instagram
followings oh they already have the
following that's what
people like online was saying because i
was trying to find the best app dude
he's so
in yeah
[Music]
it's like season two and three are the
pure fires yeah
some people like season one some people
hate it and then uh
season four everybody hates they say
it's so boring yeah and then so people
like two three and five the best one
they say is all right
and four everybody shits on six six no
one says anything about six well they're
all just real nice to each other
they're all like friends dude season
five when you get when you get 35
episodes in
there's a moment in there dude where i
was like i'm not going to cry during
reality show
what my girl was crying and she looked
at me i was like i
promise i started laughing are you going
to do the spoilers i was like
you got to wait no wait for it wait
forever just there oh my eye
i started swimming like god damn it just
[ __ ]
i looked at my grave when it got done i
went this is the best reality show of
all time
are you serious oh it's [ __ ] you're
right about the casting though uh
one of stevie's ex-girlfriend got casted
for love island she did the auditions
and rounds they found her on
instagram uh i think she was auditioning
for america when they first started
why yeah i just think
i don't know it's just different uk is
so good and they own the rights of the
music so if you notice like oh yeah i
noticed the music
is on point yeah they play like actual
like songs and i
i think maybe the uk like they just like
the brits and the scottish and
like they just have so much more fun i
feel like well let's go hang out with
them
yeah man you know i didn't they seem so
next year 2021 we'll see you and your
boy tommy fury and straight up love
yeah drop a l bomb i love you
i love you tv you say it like that yeah
i love you
i love you i always have laughs
that's braveheart right i was surprised
that he
uh get out with that girl
when uh the ring girl came in i was like
oh he's gonna switch up but he didn't
wait for it it gets so good god it gets
good bro you get so
into it no when i get i that's my thing
i can't just be half in
like diets dude i have to be so strict
yeah it can't be like you can have a
cheat day one no there can be no cheat
day yeah because if i cheat it's
i cheat how are you doing right now on
it you know
i saw you i had holland raised i had
three sandwiches on saturday i text cat
because there's one in pasadena now
and so we drove down with the kiddos you
can only get it from postmates so you
gotta wait in the parking lot postmates
picks up hands it off to you it's kind
of stupid
and then we walked to a park and ate
[ __ ] hell and raised damn
and then i got extra sandwiches because
i like them when they're cold so that
night during
the fight night and then the next day i
had one too
see how many did you have three see i
cut three three
three hot howling ray sandwiches i'm
glad to cut you off your stomach you
should was you on the toilet
no not bad not bad you're getting used
to the spices
yeah yeah i only [ __ ] with the hot only
[ __ ] with the hot dude how about this
how i get into stuff so
i'd say once or twice a year i revisit
uh the charles manson [ __ ] i love the
charles manson stuff
so i was this is podcast he kept talking
about spawn ranch and i never knew
i don't know why i never looked it up i
never knew where it was at
and so uh the podcast i was looking uh
listening to on my bike ride
they said spawn ranch and then they set
a area chatsworth and i'm like
chatsworth i'm like what's that why have
i heard of that and i'm like i know
where the [ __ ] that's at
it's not too far from my house so so
then on my bike i was on there
i looked up spawn ranch like oh [ __ ]
it's only like 11 miles from me
so i bike i'd rode my bike to spawn
ranch son
so spawn ranch is where charles banson
and the
family like all the girls they lived
there for two years
so that's where supposedly we can get
into that supposedly that's where he
came up with the plan to
uh helter skelter kill sharon tate
uh that's where he'd write his songs his
music and all that that's where all the
girls were that's where like
the music producer would visit the ranch
and
and
see him play his tunes and [ __ ] so you
go there it's a little airy but
it the the manson so he only rolled with
he only just had a bunch of girls
no he wanted more guys she wanted like
muscle but a lot of guys like
didn't really [ __ ] with him like they
thought he was weird the only reason
anyone kind of chilled with him is
because
those girls he would like they could
have whatever they want with the girls
yeah
so like terry melcher and like the like
the
the beach boy guy who was really into
him who kind of helped him out yeah and
they would chill at the beach
boys house um in the hills he would only
[ __ ] with him because
he had all these hot girls yeah and he
could [ __ ] all the girls and then they
but he didn't really do anything who or
the beach guy the
beach guy the beach guy he [ __ ] the
girls but that's it that's it and it
wasn't like he then he thought
charles manson had talent yeah and then
charles manson wrote a song
and then he took the that song and put
it on the beach boys album
and gave charles manson no credit oh and
so
he was actually a good musician he was
good he was just like on discipline so
like when they put him in a studio so
that beach boy guy and terry melcher
hooked him up and put him in studios to
get him passed by like sony
and universal but he'd get to the like
the with the
were they like audition them is what you
say you get to the sound stage
and then he'd fight with the like
control guy
because the guy like hey try this or try
this and he like pulled a knife on one
of the guys
so like people like we can't have that
we can't deal with this dude yeah and he
didn't have the talent like undeniable
yeah like if drake's not [ __ ]
pulls the knife i was like all right
we'll figure it out
all right yeah man get the [ __ ] out of
here because he wasn't really anything
no about the time he was you know he's
like this is he from here
i think no he's not from here yeah he's
not from here but what's weird what's
weird about charles manson's like
you know with like the fake news and
like to put the corona fair and
everybody
yeah the russia fake news and like the
media now is like
right they just on they they they get
views and hits off fair like selling
people fair that's that's what they do
like cnn [ __ ]
but this was real a little bit but like
even back then like they were doing the
same [ __ ] with charles manson like
like the the tom o'neil who wrote chaos
and he gets into it about the cia and
charles manson working with the cia
and yeah doing all this [ __ ] in uh hate
ashbury and san francisco like the whole
helter skelter thing
and like yeah the whole like he was this
mastermind all this like that was a
narrative that the media created
like charles manson's like what the [ __ ]
like trust me like i didn't even like
the beatles they did i heard that they
catch
it was like think of the narrative like
it's the most infamous
yeah story they call him a serial killer
to make sense so they
he's the most infamous serial killer of
our time and like that whole narrative
was kind of
it was out of the helter skelter book
that they that the
belusi wrote like that whole narrative
the prosecution
kind of made up to pitch to the courts
yeah and then the news got a hold of it
and they're you know and they said he
was going to try killing steve mcqueen
ellen john
like all these super famous people but
so i
i can't remember if you told me this or
someone told me did they like give him
like lsd
yeah they they'd ask an elsie and hate
ashbury and like oh in
prison and he would go to those and so
the
the feds or feds or d.a would have
houses where they'd give like john's as
they call them they
get them in with girls that was in the
hills yeah no no that was in uh haiti
ashby in san francisco oh god i got it
so they give you give them all this lsd
and then and and acid and all this [ __ ]
then you know in that chaos book they
talk about like they would
they knew where charles manson was at
and they would like the cops like oh
we're gonna go get him like he's on
don't touch him right now yeah and like
he got away so many times
like his parole officer never [ __ ]
like they would let him like travel when
he
shouldn't like it's super suspect so you
you think they set him up
no i think he's crazy i think he's oh
you dude he's an evil dude i just don't
buy the narrative
but he also like he like yeah he told
like maybe the narrative is he told
those people to kill everybody
but then it's like he's not a killer you
know what i'm saying like the real
killers tex watson who's his muscle yeah
and tex
watson his he did an interview and those
tapes has never been released
ever because he didn't go on the
narrative that held her skeleton
so you know what held her skelter's from
helter spielberg yeah held her skeleton
song from the beatles
helter skelter is a famous roller
coaster in england
so it's not like this evil it sounds
evil as [ __ ] helter skeleton because
because we associate with charles manson
yeah beatles like [ __ ] that's a roller
coaster
you know what i'm saying it's like
you've been going six flags yeah you
know yeah it's just like yeah that ride
it's a ride if we call it magic mountain
or splash mountain
yeah it's weird dude you look into it
it's interesting
but then and then like see where i ride
is to die for and
the reason one of the reasons got caught
is because that uh i think he named
susan
uh atkins she was she got picked up for
something else and she was in prison she
started bragging about the murders and
then one of the
uh her cellmates was like i gotta tell
someone about this
and then so and then when they killed
sharon tate like it was just
how'd they kill her dude so it was just
[ __ ] up huh dude you want me to talk
about it
i mean yeah let's get into it so
somebody didn't even let me know he
looked at me
pretty famous right pretty famous super
gorgeous
sharon tate and then uh the folger uh
daughter who you know the the coffee the
coffee yeah yeah so you got billionaires
i've seen her yeah
and then there was like two other people
in the house one one was a guy so
two girls two guys and sharon tate yes
now that old house should be terry
melcher's house he owns it
but he rented it out to them to polanski
who was sharon tate's husband roman
roman
but uh terry melcher was the owner and
also terry melcher was the guy
who could give charles manson's record
contract so charles manson tex watson
went to that house
year before way before having parties he
they'd go
for parties and he was the guy who was
the key to his success like he thought
he was going to be the beatles
he thought he was going to be like
charles manson he thought he's going to
be like jim morrison his whole family
thought he's gonna be like jim morrison
oh so they thought so when they just
were like [ __ ] it you're not getting a
record deal nothing like that
that's when he was like [ __ ] these
people these rich people are taking from
us we're going to kill the rich
so he went to the house not knowing
sharon tate or folger was in there they
just knew that somebody rich was in
there
it wasn't like uh it wasn't
they went to the house previously to
talk to terry melcher and they're like
terry melcher doesn't live here this is
roman polanski's house and like oh and
then sharon tate walked out and he saw
her she's like damn she's hot
and then left didn't think anything of
it and then when he came up with the
plan to kill everybody
he sent them there tex watson and the
three girls he sent them there was like
just kill the rich people and make it
look real gory
so sharon tate was pregnant as [ __ ] they
killed her they stabbed the baby
they they stabbed her a [ __ ] ton uh the
dude they
they stabbed like a gillian [ __ ]
times like you're talking about
how much is that just doing it
like tex watson did almost all the
killing ah
gnarly [ __ ] dude and she just happened
to be there they're just there
get killer rich yeah kill the rich and
then then
cause he was mad at the record labels
yeah because he thought it was like
they're
gonna go after the record it was like
well you wanted to because he thought
roman polanski lived there
and that's a house they got up for sale
now well this [ __ ] is wild
it's wild [ __ ] was different back then
it's kind of complex but
but then but then when you watch all of
charles manson's like interviews which
i've watched a ton of them
he's never admitted like he's like i
didn't kill those people he's like this
whole like
hippie thing and family he's like i
don't know what the [ __ ] people are
talking about
and then he goes you know i tried
shaving for this interview but they
wanted me to look crazy so i have to
leave my hair long and to have this
[ __ ] so
i look crazy so what explains the
swastika on his head he had to
in in prison he had to side with the
alien nation so they would protect them
because everyone wanted to [ __ ] want
to kill him so he had to say oh so he's
like oh i'll link up with aaron nation
so that's when he did all that [ __ ] yeah
and they
talked about that and they protected him
that makes sense because he wanted
muscle so he there was i think they're
called the straight satan's was a
motorcycle gang
and they he they used to hang out at the
ranch [ __ ] all the girls
and he tried like getting them to jump
on board with him and they're like the
[ __ ] out of here like no one took him
serious
no one took him seriously and he was
just trying to make music no yes
this guy was just trying awesome you
know what else is surprising about
charles manson you know he's 5'4
he was a little dude tiny dude 5'4
was he beating he so he didn't beat him
he didn't touch anybody
well he might have shot a guy but no he
like you he like he would get in a fight
but he didn't
do any of those murders now he did tie
up the family in
los feliz yeah he went and tied that did
he kill him nope he left
he just left oh they were just tied up
there and and then they're good and then
the sharon
no that they murdered him and then the
sharon tate family
once tex came back to the ranch it was
like yo we killed he's five two
five two bro wikipedia five two so he's
probably yeah he's from
he's from cincinnati that's where white
mike is from white mike
nope see victims nine
but the the family says uh they killed
35 what does that mean uh killed by the
proxy
he didn't do it himself he had someone
else do it oh got it like
so it'd be like saying a mafia boss is a
serial killer
because he orders the killings it you
never call a mafia guy
uh you never call uh uh uh like you know
gambino or like any of these high level
gaudio serial killer but they've killed
way more people the narrative is weird
to me shout out to boardwalk
it's all it's all super weird yeah but
but but when when he did that like la
was freaking the [ __ ] out so all the
famous people had private security
you couldn't buy any german shepherds
guns went out of stock
because everyone thought like this
killer was on the loose it took him
forever to catch him by the way
oh to catch yeah and this is what else
is weird
and so they so they they this story is
what's nuts so they kill a guy in
topanga
he was a a music instructor they killed
him
they killed the shantae family then the
next day they killed
uh the family in los feliz the stupid
[ __ ] cops didn't put any of it
together
their work in individual cases they
didn't they didn't think
it was associated with each it was it
was they never put it together till
after so it took forever
so i i have two questions
so when the the triangle like you said
it took them a minute to
put it together and it was because
they're all talking about different
pieces
that you're talking about los feliz yeah
talking about l.a lapd and it's a
penguin
which is different jurisdictions yeah
but don't the police like
reach out to these jurisdictions not
back then no
no but now they do they had like it was
like yeah now they do because like even
like the golden state killer
so he would kill all up and down the
coast yeah he's killing one
jurisdiction kill here they never put it
together
so back then they'd have to call mckay
have you that's how those [ __ ]
get away
yeah not now now it's all over like i
don't even
catch jeffrey dahmer a hot second
really a hot second so back then killing
was like easy to get away with way
easier think about no cameras
oh there's now there's a street camera
everywhere everywhere
everywhere people don't even know
nothing but that's so
what charles manson would do is he would
get these girls who had like
broken families like lost and he'd be
just like kill him with kindness and
then
give him all these drugs like lsd and if
you're a part of the
family you couldn't uh there's no
alcohol he didn't believe in drinking
you could do a bunch of like lsd and
acid and [ __ ] and marijuana but no
no drinking and so then he was supposed
to turn up
lsd but then they huge him real high and
then like spit all this [ __ ] at him all
this knowledge
so they thought he was like second
coming of [ __ ] jesus christ oh so
this is like he had them in a cult
oh dude it was a cold and they called
themselves the family yeah
someone else gave that name the family
they did an article i'm in rolling
stones
they gave him the name of family he
never referred himself as a culture
family
it's super interesting it's kind of
what's weird to me is that text what
this is where it all it all relies on
text watson's
his text text text he's from texas
oh god tex they call him tex watson he
used he was the muscle he's one who did
all the murdering he was a [ __ ]
brutal how big was he can you look at
that huge
but it all what if you want to know what
happens
those tapes have they've never released
them those are the the
those tapes will tell us what's going on
is he still alive
i don't know he's in prison for life
not that big not small though especially
think about the people back then he's
still in jail oh he's still in jail
i'm not wikipedia he's in san diego
you're gonna go now i'm gonna drive down
there what you're gonna say hey what's
your side of the story
does he i would love to hear because he
because they say they won't release his
because his
narrative on what like the the killings
isn't the helter skelter like he's like
what no we weren't killing [ __ ]
that's not why we did it we like we
weren't trying to start a race war like
you know that stuff
but then that's what they delay like you
said the media the helper skelter book
which is one of the best-selling books
of all time
it was that that painted that narrative
exactly skeleton
2014 this is him that's him in 2014. i
feel like
he still looks young yeah you look like
he got his life together i know right
what the [ __ ] you teach kids in prison
yeah i like that but people didn't want
to kill him
he didn't get linked up with the aryan
nation
no one [ __ ] ah you weak he's all
smiling
he was the one who did oh [ __ ] he's the
one that did all the killing
all the killing this guy he's the bad
guy no one talks about him
maybe he just want his credit that's why
he's just but charles manson like
like if you watch a geraldo rivera did
an interview with him
and he's like people think you're a
killer and stuff like he's like what the
[ __ ] you talking about
he's like the family's like he's not a
cult and then he's like well you seem
crazy he's like
wouldn't you be pissed if you've been
locked up for 18 years and people keep
paying this narrative like you're this
[ __ ] monster all the time yeah
he's like you guys are scared of me he's
like me
and then he goes into prison he was kind
of the first one he's like that's fake
news man he's like this narrative you
guys are painting isn't it real
got it and then he goes into prison and
they want to kick his ass so he gets
with aaron
nation and then he had such control over
the girls when he was on trial
he shaved his head they all shaved their
head he put an x here
they put an x there crazy [ __ ] dude
and but that susan atkins a piece of
[ __ ] she she did a you know
she wanted that stabshin tate in the
stomach had no
remorse for you well she looks crazy
she's a real piece of [ __ ] too she got a
pimple on her lip what is that it's got
blisters
it looks like a cold sore oh
because the whole family like someone
get it they would all get it because you
used to sleep with everybody
she so she's the one that killed sharon
tate
she says there's tex watson later down
you know laters
after but years later but
yeah it's interesting right yeah well in
lighter news
that spawn ranch is interesting because
you can go down there see where they're
all chilling like some they're rusted
out like
shits on the ground with like where they
were hiding out in there is there still
where they took [ __ ]
i'm sure they [ __ ] somewhere oh i don't
use that so what you were saying like
rust
rusted [ __ ] so that susan atkins person
died in 2009 right there oh she did
yes this whole this whole thing seems
exhausting oh it's super interesting
though especially read that chaos book
where it goes into like
no i'm just talking about all that they
did this seems so exhausting
but but don't too lazy you know what's
weird to think about like
what what would have happened if they
would have gave charles manson a record
contract
none of this would have happened if they
show it here dude yeah play your music
there's no murderer well he also could
have went independent
what the [ __ ] did he not jump on that
back then there was no two
there was no independent but now he
jumped on soundcloud
you know what i'm saying what year was
it 69
69 uh august 69
damn if someone if [ __ ] if there's a
sound cloud
that's what i'm saying he was just like
right you go independent
yourself you can do it yourself yeah you
do it obviously had some talent if like
the beach boys guy [ __ ] with him this
terrible helper [ __ ] with him like he
has been doing something
and then he he jammed out in uh that
beach boy's house
and uh with neil young and neil young
was like damn dude you can play
so he must win pretty [ __ ] talented
we heard his music remember stop saying
he knows this video
it was actually not saying no to people
or just or just
realize you can do your own thing it's
pretty good
weird we liked it oh you guys like this
creepy as that sounds
i mean it's probably yeah i get it like
you know talent is talent you wouldn't
expect him to be that good as well i
think that's the main thing
yeah he's great good but he was good he
was good he wasn't drinking
bulky [ __ ] music that's what it was back
yeah you know
yeah oh guess who i listened to
countrywide
morgan wallin no chris stapleton
let's take a little break from the
shenanigans because guess what
holiday season is here and people are
coming around
and make sure you give them good food
i'm talking about omaha steaks
right now you can get mouth-watering
steakhouse caliber packages
an exclusive price just for the t-fat kz
listeners it's called the deluxe
grillers assortment just saying the name
makes my mouth water because i'm fat
listen for 129.99
you'll get four tender
cut filet mignons eight boneless chicken
breasts
four juicy steak burgers four jumbo
franks
four wrapped scallop potatoes say what
four made from scratch caramel apple
tartlets are we
what this is crazy this package also
includes a free digital meat thermometer
so you know when your meat's ready to go
and four free omaha steak burgers go to
omahasteaks.com enter the code
fighter into the search bar and order
this package today
plus you get the free burgers and
digital meat thermometer
so you know when your meat's ready to
get off the grill
this holiday stay home and send
unforgettable gifts and eat great with
the best steak of your life
guaranteed go to omahasteaks.com type
fighter in the search bar in order today
that's omahasteaks.com keyword fighter
all right kids listen
you've heard me and chin praise kratom i
use kratom before every stand-up gig
before every podcast
i swear by kratom and here is some
kratom
and the reason why we've taken so long
to get some kratom
uh on this show is because you got to
trust them has to be
it has to be in-house a small operation
not outsourced
readable stuff you can trust we talk
about kratom
we talk about kratom you want integrity
kratom uh
that's really good and this company
prides themselves on doing things the
right way without cutting corners
uh safety is number one when it comes
to this kratom they do not outsource to
manufacturing talk about super specio
all right and you're gonna get the best
kratom on the market it's what i takes
what chin takes
i swear by i went i went push something
in your face that i didn't trust just
like anything i do
supplements freaking merch cbd
it has to be trusted it's third party
lab tested
all right you only want the good stuff
um
it's only natural ingredients and they
just do it right man so
i swear by these guys all right again
you want something pure man and
uh if you never heard of kratom it's a
herbal supplement kind of like cbd but
instead of coming from the cannabis
plant
it's from something closer to a coffee
tree people use kratom
every day including myself chin uh
people use it for
to get relief from pain energy support
all right kind of like a substitute for
coffee or pre-workout
man's stress i use it for focus i swear
by kratom i stay on it
um and yeah man super speciosa
is the kratom for you guys so if you
just want to try it out this is the best
way to start
because it's safe and they're offering
you guys 20 off go to getsuperleaf.com
again that's getsuperleaf.com
that's super leaf super l e a f
dot com enter the promo code fighter for
20
off that's getsuperleaf.com promo code
fighter
yeah oh guess who i listened to
countrywide oh
morgan wallin no uh chris stapleton
oh yeah this is good wow
legend you win not gonna i i'm in yeah
i'm in i was thoroughly impressed
so uh i've just cycled this music i
can't remember anything
which one is your favorite uh specifics
i just let it ride because it was just
that good yeah he has some good jazz
he's got some
really good jams you're cruising around
your jeep less than that no
no oh no you're not getting you're not
gonna bump it like that not yet oh okay
you gotta warm up you're not there yet
i'm not there yet
it's still oasis and you're only in your
home and you're probably saying yeah the
privacy of my home
let me get comfortable there first and
then then i'll take it outside
and take you down the street i see what
you did take it just take it to the
streets
of the streets because no he's he's
really good though so good his guitar
playing is great
yeah amazing chris stapleton's the one
that did the song with uh
justin timberlake too yeah say something
right you heard that type of
chris stapleton say something i'm giving
up on you
nope nope that's not him i like say
something with uh drake and timberland
hold on no chris and uh justin
timberlake dude a banger
thank you so much dude yeah he's really
where's he from
look tennis how does he i think because
he's he's wrote a song tennessee no and
i just guess
i can't see you i don't know though
that's the one i looked up dude country
music's the only guys can get away with
wearing baseball caps at
[ __ ] i know they're just major like
dressed like the undertaker at
wheresomania
[Music]
this isn't it i respect it all the way
that just gave me chills when he opened
that no his video say something's
ridiculous
yeah like he's his voice is just like uh
i don't know
like it's a dirty angel it's a powerful
like a dirty angel dirty angel is that
what he says that's what i
call him oh that's i think that's
country dirty angel yeah is that it's
great
how tall is so good yeah
he dropped his solo album oh was it
justified
uh no it's just self-titled cry me a
river
yeah so pharrell did that whole album
yep he did
produced it yeah it is you know
originally it was for prince right no
no uncle jackson yep mj wow but yeah i
didn't like it and so
gave it to timberlake timberlake [ __ ]
senorita
i feel for you come on come on now
you ever seen it was it called justify
yes it was justified yeah i know
yeah two wells um did you you ever seen
him live or anything
justin timberlake no but i would go to
i'd be front row
oh from say let's front [ __ ] row dude
he comes i'm buying his tickets let's do
it i'm with justin if
he's a good actor too well let's not go
too far
shut the [ __ ] up bro you don't like that
teacher you're a [ __ ] hater you don't
like
you know what i love dogs true story
it's a true
through the story listen damn that [ __ ]
me up even more because the movie is
[ __ ] me up
yes don't worry i got you i got you yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
you just get in the oh dude that's the
truth you got life for that you got life
that's i didn't know there was a team
i didn't like him at all in that movie
honestly you're a piece of [ __ ] yeah
you're a piece of [ __ ]
come on what else has he been coming
from an actor yeah bad teacher let me
see
cameron diaz didn't make the movie the
the the the redhead
girl yeah she's good she was not super
bad she
she eats the apples no she's not
superman the red hair emma
um
okay but she was in something else as
well though she's in a lot of things
pretty hot she's a british actor correct
yeah she's so good
when he's taking a [ __ ] he's like you
know this is not the time to bother him
he's like you know this is my daily dump
wait this is not time
back to his acting you don't [ __ ] with
justin timberlake's acting he's not no
you're a [ __ ] he's pretty good yeah you
know what your promise miley he's coming
out
you're coming at big sean justin
timberlake you're talking about two guys
who were
cemented in their [ __ ] lanes
jt is cemented in music huh
acting no big sean is cemented
in having a record deal music no so i
want you to i want you to understand
you know you know uh you're crazy you're
talking about justin timberlake's also
the voice
of the head troll and one of the biggest
animations of all time called trolls my
biggest animation is one of
trolls is big massive he's the voice of
trolls well i can
you can you can do a voiceover
everywhere you can do a voiceover like
i'm back there i thank you i was just on
a set movie set this weekend
and i know what it takes uh movie set or
xbox commercial
well you have to say that to the
audience i don't know right commercials
the movie set live like like you're on
alpha dawg
right yeah like he was in the house we
didn't see you in alpha dog
i didn't know you were like was in the
social network oh it wasn't social
networking
if you see justin timberlake acting in
the cook like any kind of movie
oh i gotta go see it now that's all i'm
saying and the fans would agree with me
on this
what do you mean i think he's good yeah
he he's okay but in alpha i don't know i
thought he could have didn't get her
that's what i'm saying
who are you comparing you know you are
you know what you are you're the hater
online you're the kid who can't get into
the club
hating on the people in the club waiting
in line night after roxbury [ __ ] did
chris brown say that
yeah you why you you're that guy look at
me now that's not me that's not me
that's you right now that's me just
saying like he ain't even good he's like
calling hold miami's what are you what
are you saying yeah yeah
what's the podcaster comic talking about
oh my god what's the guy with 20 000
followers talking about
i got more than that it's growing thank
you fans but but i'm saying okay
i'm saying i didn't like him in alpha
dog okay i'm just i'm saying
it don't matter bro you tripping he's
good crazy he's a beast was that his
alpha dog
first roll no it wasn't his personal i
don't know it wasn't his first vlog
god he was good and he's the first thing
i knew him dude
that's crazy that it's a true story
break your heart the guy from the
uh what's he got the girl next door uh
emil
that guy's that guy's a good actor i'm
just saying
what was his first role it said
something that just made it on to uh
hold on he was a disney kid though yeah
he was a parking mouse club
and ryan gosling yeah they grew up right
now
and uh
his first roll here we go right here
that boy got credit credit
talking about that shut up he's in this
[ __ ] since he was a kid malik
well hold on oh in time [ __ ] that
movie's good he did the music i think so
let's see
oh yeah amanda seifried was in it again
he was okay
the wonderful world of disney jason the
simpsons
i was a voice simpson voices look long
shot i remember that he was a valet that
was ice cube i remember that
one john give me something good yeah
his own music videos yeah yeah alpha
who's his first major role yeah first
major role okay 14 years
after his like [ __ ] solo album he
didn't know what he was doing i get it
they said this went straight to the uh
video release edison
oh okay then after that he would oh he
was in black snake mold shout out to
samuel jackson
oh that one yeah remember that shrek i
forget he's in shrek he's in shrek he
was singing yeah
no he's not sitting on there he's a
voice on track he's he's the prince
the lonely island dick in the box he
said love the love group taking
a box he got credits
oh yeah he did a lot on snl too wait
what
he did a lot of sketches on uh snl oh
friends with benefits friends with
benefits
yes and you know she's married to ashton
kutcher and they
came out with the other they were on the
70s show but that same year they had
another like friends with benefits
movies just go with wait no it was with
uh natalie
porter portman yeah i forgot what that
one was called but it's this and she did
it with ashley
yeah yeah that's so funny and time was
so great
ashley kutcher was with demi moore for a
minute yeah the more the women baby
come on man you know is that much is did
they have a huge age gap
yeah yeah huge yeah yeah that's what
inspired me to talk about 70 euro
yes yeah yeah her daughter's she's not
70. no that's inspired me to go to my
68 68 year i mean yeah dude you can't
just sit here when you hate on not just
to really
i'm not you know what you know what
you can't do that you can't do a dog did
you almost fire your mouth
what you mean i was trying to think what
beanie siegel said to uh
to charlemagne oh when uh that he's like
you don't he's like you're not qualified
you're not you do your google
he's like you're not qualified
i remember that yeah catches a fate he's
like you're not qualified
he gets so heated that looks crazy and
when you think why
shot him be quiet what's up what's up
everybody
what's up man because the incident that
occurred like i said
ain't nobody in a right mind going stand
straight in front of me go to the
last minute of it that's when it gets
real heated uh-huh you're writing no
personality man
don't come
[Laughter]
it's dangerous it's dangerous
no doubt you talking muscles
like he literally he's not even scared
he's accused of murder during the height
of my career you should have been your
job is to play games
shouldn't he shouldn't be safe man don't
play with me
and he set up i know that's how i know
he was for real because when you adjust
your seat
because you're there you're not
qualified you're not qualified you're
not quite
from my world remember sticky fingers
gotta charlemagne cause i mean through
your googles bee
i didn't get it i did it i googled it he
was fighting he was right
well they were going in because
charlemagne stinky figure you know
sticky fingers is right
no is he the cross-eyed dude or no no no
sticky fingers is the
the bald hair guy he was in a lot of
movies she's a rapper as well onyx
charlemagne onyx yeah yeah oh god i got
it troubleman's been threatened so many
times so many [ __ ] times i've been
beat up
i love i love it on video i love how he
trolls people that's so funny
is he a troll he's a troll or is he just
like i think he's just a no [ __ ]
type of like yeah he is he's gonna like
what people are uncomfortable asking
because his boy and his group is cross
side oh yeah
yeah yeah you're talking about what
that's not cross side now or cockeyed
all right
no mods are not crosstalk you're right
it's not crosstalk it's not
cocked either that thing is doing what
they want
i don't don't do i always thought that
dude was looking like donnell rollins uh
what's my man name in the middle yeah i
always thought i don't know
i can't even think his name yeah they
gonna kill him um
you ain't no i don't think he's a troll
i don't think he's trolling
no no he just asked like what would like
i think he just asked
the questions the uncomfortable
questions
the questions that no one [ __ ] wants
to be asked oh i watched uh schultz
special
oh you finally watched it it's great huh
yeah it's not it's not like a comedy i
think if people are tuning into like a
comedy
it's not a comedy special that's more of
like a comedy
it's more like monologue like like
current events like the daily news with
with yeah feels really good
oh dude he does really good jokes
crushes it yeah
it's really good i really i really think
he's doing his actual special in two
years
yeah yeah i think it's just a i mean if
people haven't watched this it's just a
good eye-opener
when it comes to all the [ __ ] that's
like costly going on in this [ __ ]
world
it's gonna be hard for anyone to come
after him because everybody gets it
everybody gives it man
everybody white chinese yeah i love it
because most people don't think like
that they just think for one
one [ __ ] side you know did you watch
it
i watched the first one i got i got
three more yeah i was busy i was filming
this week oh yeah there's four parts
are you filming oh okay what's jt on set
no jake
ain't got time for that it's premiering
performing at the super bowl yeah he was
the halftime show yeah halftime show
i'm not going with janet jackson titty
well damn it that was so disrespectful
now two
how's that disrespectful guys what
happened the head of xbox said they're
gonna fly me to the super bowl i just
wanna let you know the two bro that's
what
we're talking about we're in talks no
we're not in talks but here's the thing
i want them wait wait it's premiere
doing the super bowl beg
justin timberlake to go to the [ __ ]
super bowl they'd have to pay him to go
to the super bowl
yeah true well well if if an xbox
commercial is premiering
the date i think you're gonna go to the
super bowl i don't know if they're gonna
have fans there
yeah yeah in february yes this is in
february
super hot this year next year chin they
said somewhere i should know about
but uh they haven't finished you're not
going to wait here
oh yeah yeah they're going to be fanned
up
but yeah also the director said he i
hate when people because i was walking
around set
cocky why oh because i was you know i'm
going to fight
like he just didn't realize that look
but go well here's the thing
you know how i got it i don't want to
expose people but i was like you know i
know the producer
so i'm thinking i'm hot [ __ ] so i'm
walking around it's like hey your
trailer's right here i said it better be
right so i get to the trailer horrible
what do you mean
well anyway so anyway anyway so i get on
set but i'm a very professional guy
so i was like hey i was like what's up
he's like uh what [ __ ] what do you want
to call you
i said call me rb right and he was like
okay cool we'll call you rb because the
character name was gb
gamer boy i was like nah i'm not a gamer
boy just call me rb rolly boy right so
jose they always call me rb you've had a
relics for one week
i said about two months but okay so
let's so he goes
i was like yo i'm gonna fight her in the
kids with the z he was like oh yeah yeah
yeah
is that what uh that i was like brendan
shot me he's like yeah i know brendan
shop he's from colorado right
i was like denver he was like yeah uh
what's is point hill or
uh point something the auto box where's
the out of box capital
he was saying like autobots yeah outer
box capital auto
autobots transformers oh no outer
battery boxes i'm sorry like the
are they colorado company yeah wherever
yeah the headquarters let's see
all right because he said i'll get to
the next part real quick
it's in yeah before college there it is
that's where csu is that that's where
jay went to school
i'm glad you brought that up so he was
like i grew up
for college all my life i know those
guys they went to uh
csu i went to see you jay went to csu
well one of y'all csu's the shitty
college
okay so he said i know brenda
i'm not trying to be in your xbox
commercial i don't give a [ __ ]
justin timberlake yeah the guy said he
know you he said he's a big fan
and keep going he's like yo i love
britney shop he knows me i was like okay
cool
and i sent you the group chat and you
asked him i said mike i said yo brent
this guy said he knows you
i was like oh his name is mike he's like
mike who and now i was like i said his
last name
britney sends a clown emoji
doing the thumbs down with both hands
it's ronald mcdonald going
shaking his head i didn't know what to
say because i was like oh [ __ ]
this guy was right next to me i was like
yeah
maybe i do i'm bad with nate i'd have to
see him yeah yeah yeah
he's not a native guy no not at all he
said he'd been to the uh your show at
wise guys
really yes the recent one no uh last
year did you have did you perform last
year yeah
yeah i'd have to see him if i see him i
bet i know okay well he's no disrespect
well yeah he's still ain't trying to be
in that commercial though
wait hold on
it's a big deal it's premieres during
the super bowl so you're going to be on
the super bowl commercial yeah i'm the
lead
i'm the lead that my co-star she's
australian don't worry about her i
had she's going to see this and it's
going to hurt her i know right yeah
well i told her that i was like yo pick
up the tempo oh really yeah i told her
that she knew
so yeah she what she's been doing bro
you've been on right this [ __ ]
creed dude you had a boxing role in
cream
dude you're acting like you're robert de
niro
you act like you played something out of
character [ __ ]
giving tips and [ __ ] she's like what
yeah you [ __ ] mouth
a boxer played a boxer yeah good [ __ ]
job hold on
here's the thing you're a boxer playing
a boxer and then you got a fight with
the other co-star yeah
well you know what you aren't you're a
problem i'm not a problem on set don't
don't say that that's gonna be a
statement i'm not a problem
because i post a picture of uh the me
like behind the scenes can't have it and
it was like bro it's a because it's
it's a big release that they're going to
surprise the world and you didn't know
that i didn't you also sat on a mclaren
ah this guy yeah that was crazy dude
that was absolutely
on a podcast yeah you sat on a mclaren
and the dealer was like what the [ __ ]
and i got up real fast like
what are you doing
is this call out malignant well no you
brought on yourself you're the one
talking all this [ __ ] yeah like
that boy i don't know call me try giving
some actor notes
can i set the scene for you by the way
i'm the lead she's number two
on the call she it goes malik b number
one she's number two
but still it's a commercial you know
it's not like you're in [ __ ] avatar
three yeah
there's no there's no leader
[Applause]
no but this this is gonna propel me to
other things so i'm saying
i'm taking this seriously not with this
attitude no no no i'm taking this
seriously i'm like yo you want
listen mike loves no brilliant shop he
loves me as well i'm telling her that
i'm like listen
we trying to kill this scene do you
deliver your lines like this
how long has she been doing it though
she said she's been acting like all her
life
you're an [ __ ] what do you mean how
are you gonna get you've been acting for
three minutes right hello brother when
you got it you got it now
yeah i guess yeah but she's australian i
was like listen
i think was she hot yeah she was hot but
here's the thing she was she was tall to
them australians are so tall
and i was like yo thank god you ever
been to australia nah
just dine piece walking everywhere yeah
she's been australia
everywhere yeah it's like they just stay
out there she taught me australian
accent you should say you gotta like
they talk through their nasal mostly so
you just like
instead of saying they don't move their
lips a lot so instead of saying
like you know we move our lips like um
just talk to your name so uh
bloody how like that kind of like
[ __ ] horror was awful
yeah so we said that all right let me
just tell you how to send your thing
like i want people to act like
are you in trouble for xbox for telling
the commercial before it drops in the
super bowl
right you're about to you already got
you already got you already got it
you're about to lose an xbox gig
no you're about to lose your spine
finally
what's the director's name who knows me
mike mike wait let's
talk i want to get him out of there wait
no no
don't do that no i'm just saying uh also
also at premieres doing the super bowl i
want y'all to let y'all know and we do a
pickup shoot
in january they love me so much they was
like yo can you come back for a pickup
shoot
i told that i mean again that means like
they want to reshoot
uh for like so let's say the special
cause there's a lot of special effects
yeah let's say the guy was like i can't
do this we gotta do a pickup shoot
and uh re-shoot some same pickup shooter
is a good thing it's a great thing and
you get paid
yeah i got an xbox a new one you already
have it already yeah they gave it to me
can i show you can i see you in the
picture
have you been playing it you've been
wasting your life playing it no not i've
been busy
i had to record wait so you can talk
about all this right like you're not
yeah
because i'm you know i'm not gonna get
in trouble okay they the picture i
posted
they was like bro take that down because
there's a reveal
of you know better than that it was a
reveal for a video game yeah it was like
some it's gonna be so dope
she should know better than that but i
don't think i don't think
he sat on him you think he knows better
[ __ ] you
what's up and how about he just doesn't
know how about when peter
you know who makes the highlight and
sends the team like what do you guys
think he posted before me
before even anyone goes oh that's great
post it dude nashville let us [ __ ]
i apologize i did do that i did do that
i did do that you paying them too i was
i was like
but hold on i can't that cannot be fair
that wasn't my fault
peter texts me and he goes what song he
said what song should i
i hold on chan i'm sending it to you i'm
air dropping it okay
he's got the air drop down i don't know
if he does does he yeah i got it right
here all right let's see
chin oh there you go yep oh there we go
look at this
so they gave us they gave us all this
product and you're not posting
anything you shouldn't right no no no no
sure i'm positive sure all right
this is at your house i haven't played
xyz probably 15 years look at this
and then you can clip yourself oh is
that the baddie yeah six figures yes oh
then you like play i don't know like
makes it like this
and then your phone's here and then
you're like playing and you're like
that's the hand of six-figure queen
do people already have this xbox uh a
couple
like they say isn't it are you sure you
can post that yeah
listen we're not the reveal is something
else it's the game or something
yeah got it got it okay okay but xbox or
uh the hard one to get is the ps5 right
and then like impossible to bruh
me and my that's what she was going to
give me for my birthday
huh you're an xbox yeah but you want a
ps5 i want a ps5
god dude this guy's all up in the videos
in the xbox commercials
he's [ __ ] out you know you adjusted
the campaign
a lot for a better commercial yeah you
know what brittany i do want an xbox
yeah you'd rather have the xbox all
right that's fine any day i'm i'm
comfortable i have a great christmas
now now ps5 has travis scott xbox says
you
yeah so which one don't say it
i'm just saying the marketing dollars
for ps5 i feel like we're a little
steeper what are you talking about well
they have me see how much money traffic
scott made in
2020 i think 100 mil 100 you made 100
million because mcdonald's mcdonald's
nike collab and then this oh no not
including the thing he did for uh
that game for tonight well that's what
i'm saying that's in the team fortnight
uh playstation mcdonald's and then his
nike club
hundred mill 100 meal this year easy
good but they're saying
sales once you sign up with mcdonald's
went through the [ __ ] roof yeah for
mcdonald's yeah because of his
they're already i feel like mcdonald's
mcdonald's already popping
bro donald's don't even need to make
commercials you get when you get off the
highway
yeah yeah right when you get off oh man
dude the people are [ __ ] with me
they just built and they just opened
chick-fil-a oh yeah
and it's like it's so easy you're like
you're just like oh okay
yeah you could turn and go straight just
got
said he he would eat the kale salad get
the [ __ ] out of my face
i got a chicken say that yeah dude get
the [ __ ] out of my face
he said i go to chick-fil-a and get the
kale salads i'm like
just make your own kale fudge right
salad if you just get that every day
i don't know why why why even tempt
yourself the [ __ ] kale kell is trash
dude now i was going a little aggressive
the chick-fil-a nuggets
that's the kale salad at chick-fil-a i
don't know
why go through the drive-through and the
drive-through is always crunk as [ __ ]
it is always what's crazy to me is the
drive through a chick-fil-a is
way shorter than drive-through in and
out dude every time i pass by
in and out it's always pegged dude and
i'm like what is the three blocks
three three blocks from my house in and
out between there's
panda and then right off my exit [ __ ]
chick-fil-a you just you just yeah
that's the big man upstairs going dude
stay fat you're thick the lord is
testing you
yeah in and out bro i'm not like well
you have cheat days
every day is a cheat day hey
i've been holding it strong maybe i'll
inspire you yeah you know
you know what's inspiring is the cast of
uh
island everyone's shredding everybody's
shrimp i told my girl like you imagine
if i first chilled out with my shorts
in the pool that i know what the [ __ ] is
it bro they got the shorts like above
the knees
i love their fashion they're fashionable
i love their fashion but i could never
dress that way
yeah you could give me whatever you want
you do whatever you want i could i could
do whatever i want but i could never
they're them boys like these these are
super baggy pants on love island
oh bro they dude when they wear like
dude they don't get lit up in america
wrote
wearing those but they look cool in them
yeah their pants are so
they're like yeah they're all like
really well fashioned well
i wonder if they know no no they don't
give them a budget for uh clothing they
have to bring their own clothes
oh so basically you know fashion goes
europe
starts the trend then it gets to new
york and then it gets it's
we get it last then it goes to l.a we
get the trends last
it's like in new york that's why i've
been wearing dickies for [ __ ] 20
years
yeah um but then japan's fusion uh
fashion so japan and denim and kicks
yeah like they're clowns
with sakai and the best denim comes from
japan
well korean has though fashion karina's
have dope fashions they do
but then europe like especially england
influences all of it then he gets to new
york
yeah and then makes it way through the
midwest then he gets to us
korea's got that futuristic [ __ ] yeah
and it's also very like uh
ambiguous female-ish you know guys can
dress sort of
you know feminine like prince like my
son my son was watching bts and his
daddy are
there are those girls i'm like that's a
good question
i think a few struggle with the pronouns
for sure
and it's true look at that yeah it's
just yeah
it's just different it's just they have
that kind of but i feel like that
that won't hit here till like later i 90
years two years from now
have you seen playboy playboy carter he
dresses like that
really man some of the fashion but also
fashion trends you gotta realize the
industry needs to make money so they're
not gonna make money just putting out
the same [ __ ]
so someone's influenced it all the time
yeah baggy
and then that goes out so they stop
making baggy then tight jeans
are in then that goes away then baggy
comes back like it's just them
shilling us and getting us to spend our
money i didn't get to alexander mcqueen
and rick owens
until like i heard it in the asap rocky
songs what is that
it's like a fake asap rocky will jack
you off now so yeah you'll be careful
well this is the early asap rocky
dude why don't you say you don't think
you would jack the boys off back then
he's with rihanna
it's good to note though like oh you
know he likes guys too well i just like
thinking
it's just interesting no just note he's
just noting it yeah it's just like oh
yeah i'm just saying something i
i thought recently something happened in
that sweet in jail with him
and i was like that's what yeah that's
what you was giving me this whole
conspiracy that
something's happening yeah bro he wasn't
even jailed that long came out feminine
what are you talking about you have you
been to sweden jail
i heard have you been to swedish jail i
heard about it you heard about it bro a
couple i have friends in sweden bro a
couple of fans told me it's not there's
nothing to play with
it's different over there that's why
that's why i'm in here it's no it's not
there was like he was begging to tweet
it
better tweet in prison it's horrible bro
listen they treat him like a celebrity
he like listen they don't know who he is
wait that's a swedish jail it looks like
a university no sweden's known for being
pretty
yeah what are you talking about the fans
don't lie to me
why are you listening to fans online i
don't know what the [ __ ] they're talking
about i got i got to stop
looking yeah stop reading it but i'm i'm
saying listen he came
out [ __ ] jelly was in can we both can
we both agree that's a holiday can we
all agree
that he came out more feminine when he
left sweden i think he was always
feminine you think so always
he didn't he's good looking he's with
rihanna he didn't paint his nails and
stuff like that until he
started getting out like all this like
those nails into your hive no
they're not doesn't mean they're gay no
i'm sorry i don't think he's gay i think
he's bi
but he says he's bi that's not me
[ __ ] he did
oh wait wait i thought he said he's
didn't didn't someone get mad that he
can't his homie got mad that he uh is
they
rihanna or something like that didn't um
i think someone's upstairs they're
probably
people say that drake is upset because
like drake's in love with rihanna but i
don't know about that
drake's in love with rihanna oh yeah
yeah oh everyone's in love with rihanna
yeah i'm team rihanna rihanna's a goat
she is a goat she's a [ __ ] goat
she does whatever she wants i know right
you're talking about someone coming out
during the quarantine rihanna came up
this year
she's a shooter now lingerie her laundry
and her makeup her makeup killed it
the thing about that that's all online
she's close to it that's all online
though
okay what you're saying with travis
scott point he did it outside
everything okay yeah he was hustling
this year damn
damn and dropping music too and dropping
music get some features
i was about to say just features but
rihanna hasn't come out well no he had
that michael jordan so he's they're
selling a video with michael jordan's
house yeah
how boss you have to be to shoot a video
at michael jordan house you got to be
signed by
the the chicago house uh that's for sale
by the way it's for the sale also i know
we want to talk about sports
okay cool lamelo ball the youngest one i
didn't see did you do well
bro he's killing right now is he it's a
pass that can i send this to you chin
yeah right no just look it up chin i i
think it's on bar stool right oh here it
is
it's everywhere yo i
when he looped it here's the thing
though those right scouts don't miss
that i mean if they're saying he's that
good he must be [ __ ] good
now the middle brother got cut right
yeah lavar went down he's already said
that trash or
are you serious and look in the clutch
moment hey he played against the the
homie terrence ross oh did he no he
wasn't i think he was in uh it's
pre-season oh there you go
he's right there that was filthy that
was that all he did or
no he did more passes than that but did
he have did he put a point to anything
yeah i mean he they
they said he won one for ten that game
but it doesn't matter he had 12 assists
one for ten dude that pass was dope do
it one more time look
at all the highlights he has more
highlights oh do you see they're talking
about hard and
uh toronto to give her no to denver
today no
i swear to god for jamal yet so yeah for
jamal murray
a couple of draft picks and will borton
is it gonna happen will they talk
they're in talks
i'll be the first one get a heart in
jersey this is so dope are you are you
like that
the nuggets [ __ ] yeah that's not not him
him and the joker y'all moved
on you gotta go with sizzler you got you
got points
you got porter junior who's like gonna
be merged as a superstar yeah
harden slows the ball down he sold the
offense down yeah i
wanted to go to brooklyn you got boy boy
oh no that's not good
brooklyn looking scary this year this is
he was right about brooklyn i'm not a
slim reaper i've never been worried but
lebron is he playing oh yeah yeah
they're balling oh they are kyrie's a
[ __ ] ball
and kyrie you're good together they are
killing right they're like they blew up
they blew out boston it wasn't even a
game
yeah that's what's weird about the trade
rumors i heard hardwood source go to
boston or toronto
wait what yesterday it was boston and
toronto now just morning
today they must move so fast they just
they trying to get
listen and i want to get off this hardin
i feel like you you you being an [ __ ]
like what do you mean like that
organization catered to
you so much yes they did everything for
horton and the fact that he tried
it's just not just not working but now
they have a new coach and this guy
he's been putting his time in the first
black hole now we're minorities right
the black coaches we don't get a lot of
opportunities
i'm saying we like i'm a black coach my
bad you're not minorities in basketball
but karen okay
cool as owners yeah but
not an nba i'm talking about coaches
though it's a few black coaches right
okay
and they he has a superstar like james
harden demarcus cousins
and john wall and hardin was like now i
want to play for you that's kind of
[ __ ] up
that's just my opinion what are you
talking about they cater to it i wonder
why
he's been there for years he's done now
they got rid of the coach because he was
like it's not working for heart like him
mike yeah it's not worth antonio right
mike dancing what's wrong with him
wanting to start fresh
the organization did they built around
like cater to him
see ya then but was that bad i don't
have a problem with it because they
as soon as soon as he starts to slack
they get rid of them so
like whenever you do that like you have
[ __ ] up i give you that because it's
so cutthroat i give you that but it's
it's like with uh your boy
for the eagles to start with the white
oh my god let's talk about that
forget closer
come on man they still lost and they
suck but he put up numbers do 300
passing yards and rush
i think he had 400. no uh uh murray had
400.
oh sh they were born we had 400. okay
this is the game that white mike owes
you
whiskey on no that's college white mike
he's supposed to drop it off tomorrow
cat's after dark
make sure he drops it off um i live with
him yeah i know make sure he has it
i hate to come over there and rough both
of you um
but oh i went yeah so once it's been
awful all year but here's the promise
see this is sports so uh wentz remember
before he got hurt he's going to mvp
that year gets hurt
the foals comes in they win the super
bowl then that year they pay went out
the
ass so all the organizations money goes
into wentz
he he sucks now but they're tied up in
this huge contract
we can't sign anybody else because all
their money's in wentz pete wentz
no how dare you fall out boy no so
so then he's not playing well but all
their money's in him so but they drafted
jalen hurts in the second round i think
yeah
and he came from oklahoma uh played for
uh alabama
he's everywhere he goes he's a winner so
finally give him a shot
because wence has been shitty all season
they give him a shot
they beat the saints falls out but then
whence they was like they're gonna have
to trade him they gotta get rid of him
because he's like i'm not a backup
[ __ ] you're not even playing like a
backup you playing like uh
by the way if you come to the bronx oh
well go to the broncos
listen my saints my poor saints oh yeah
yeah
[ __ ] i know drew brees please retire him
like i
listen i hope would you rather have what
you talking about
drew brees the guy who came throw a
perfect bullet for 30 yards that guy
oh you want halon harding all the [ __ ]
that drew brees has done for the new
orleans saints bro i didn't even
playoffs last year the playoffs last
year drew brees
like uh we was playing terrible they
don't matter you guys ain't beating the
chiefs
well that's that's in the nfc though
yeah that's super ball
you guys didn't even get there you know
he's a nice guy i met him he's great
i'm saying i'm talking about for sports
features i'm talking about i'm pretty
sure even if he's a nice he's just he's
just older he's older
he's yo listen like tom brown i like
hill though everyone hates on hill i
like tyson
he was balling listen when they put him
in the game they should have left him in
he's a hey sean payton you should be
fired
yesterday no oh yes okay
i like how tom brady's balling now yeah
they were losing and they came back
i love that because i like him better
than belichick i don't like belichick
you don't like bellator really i like
but i was doing this guy i was wrong
i was rooting for cam newton though but
then he needed to do that he's just not
well he doesn't have any tools he
doesn't know anything he doesn't have
anything that defense is solid yeah but
oh he's got no people to back him up
he's like no one to throw to like julian
elements hurt like they don't have any
weapons nothing how about and then
they're blaming cam noon he's like [ __ ]
i have no one to throw to
we don't have a running back we have no
receivers nothing i'm the whole officer
and then my [ __ ]
ram my my team my team's the broncos
they suck so i watch the rams because
around every [ __ ] day
uh in l.a but and they lost to the jets
yep rams
gonna [ __ ] around lose that first pick
nah nah they did it
they made jacksonville jackson oh yeah i
forgot about jacksonville by the way
they got jaguar
by uh ravens also i don't know how you
did you watch the canelo fight this
weekend oh yeah
you like this dominated well my fam so
my girl's from
canelo's hometown guadalajara okay when
he fights they have these big parties at
my house
but my mama's born and raised in england
so i root for all english fighters
fury's my favorite fighter
he's from manchester i root for all
english fighters why so i was rooting
for smith cause he just told you what
i'm trying my mom's from there i'm not
yeah
found the best fighter on the planet by
my hands down bar none best fighter on
the planet i i
got to disagree uh canelo i got it who
but right now yep pound for pound yep
terrance crawford
he has arrangement he has a resume to
list that oh really who's his last
few facts go okay he didn't fight anyone
he fights
he fights nobody i'm a big earl spitz
guy me too name his last four fights
they
a fatal almost a fatal accident and cup
takes in the top three
danny garcia that accent means nothing
not even a tune-up fight it does it
doesn't matter dang dang garcia is older
so he beat a smaller danny garcia a
smaller dinner than any other
he's also older so he'd be danny garcia
then he beat up a tiny
mikey garcia are you i mean look at what
canelo's doing
four division world champion i give you
and he goes to their strengths
yes so
he's 20 undefeated 26-0 also he's
six three no he's that was five eight
exactly and
i like colin smith uses his height he
doesn't use his height it wasn't even a
competition though
oh listen i give you canelo is a beast i
want to say i want to see invite
demetrius andre i want to see him fight
uh one of the charlo twins i want to see
him fight triple g
again i want to see him fight keller
give me some contest
give me a listen i respect you stop
fighting his last fights were a lot of
english
dudes because you know eddie knows and
then and then he went
he went up to middleweight and fought
the russian cat what's his name man
roger ward already took his soul you're
talking about kovalev
now he took his soul though dude but
canelo's smaller and dropped his
knocked him out okay okay fight charlo
fight kayla plant
fight some heavy fight even david
benavidez fight some guys billy joe
saunders whatever it is he's supposed to
fight billy joe sanders yeah but billy
jump b
b okay you think billy joel is top
middleweight middleweight i'm just
saying
you think the charles b billy joe
saunders easy even even with the
steroids you're crazy even with this
stuff oh dear
even when i said it even with this thing
so you know him and canelo are supposed
to fight but then he posted this
yeah i saw that bad taste video saying
how to beat up a girl
but they were supposed to fight i know
that was bill joshua is a bad
[ __ ] he's not going to get past
demetrius andrade the billy joel
though that's a great fight by the way
okay all right i'm glad we got that you
hate on english fighters
he hated on jt today hates on big sean
michael english english fighters but but
then you're going to watch our
[ __ ] you don't watch violence
why don't you watch love island america
[ __ ]
are you calling him a culture yeah yeah
you stealing our culture
our english culture we're gonna calm
down you like our fast your jeans are
tight you like our fashion show right
all english brittany come back bro come
back to us
yo he gets rowdy a little bit damn bro
i'm just i love english fighters i'm
juicing he's gonna be tyson fury
no one's being enticed up here nobody
even with joshua no one's beating tyson
joshua's joshua's english as it gets too
bro no one's beating tyson fury we both
agree that and i think the world agrees
but i'm saying as far as canelo
and all jokes aside i think he should
he's not the best possible
here's the other thing think how long
he's been doing it he's 30 years old
he's been doing it think how long
and i give you and his only loss
whatever
you say to the goat his only loss to the
grace of all time when he was 21 years
old
yeah yeah but he was not ready that's
why that's why he may really bottom at
the time well then
we both can agree that after he fought
floyd he became floyd he started picking
up like floyd tendencies in his style
but i'm saying this
he fights like a real mexican too it
comes forward and he has defense
but i'm saying give me like another
would they ever fight again
who no no no floyd would never do not
floyd no why not he would
he do it now floyd knows how to lose
like canelo's in his prime why would
floyd fight canelo for a lot of money
when he could fight jake paul for a
payday
museum yeah that's why he's doing it
it's weird to me when people don't
understand that
what like what why why floyd's fight
like logan paul
and why is it happening why is it
happening it's like because he's making
money and it's no threat to him yeah and
he's tons of views like what is why
why can't people figure that out like
people thought i said how much does
logan paul weigh 200 hmm
he's way bigger than that i talked to my
boy uh
uh he's like floyd mayweather cousin
dejuan he was like floyd is
in great shape though like people love
joy's in shape
and you know he gets mcdonald's all damn
all the time
eats mcdonald's a ton all the time all
the time yo raising canes as well yeah
he pulls up in his [ __ ] phantom and
gets uh mickey dies
he's horrible drink coke drink like i'm
like god damn
beast really yeah bruh beasty no diet
oh you just train so much he's a monster
yeah
so he just burns all of it off yeah
that's all you got to do
i think he's he's gifted man he's so
tough you could do it though oh you
think it's
not right yeah it's genetics like i'm a
mesomorph i'm like a bigger person
yeah what's what's the fur that you were
i always wanted to actually what's the
furthest you bite
30 something miles like 34 34. that's
that's dope
how long how long two hours two and a
half when you're gonna do the san fran
top of the year
yeah i won't do the training yeah yeah
january i could do it now yeah you can
do it now i can do it now
dude i'll be i'll be your uh what do
they call it your helper
you know like when the people are doing
marathons they have their they're
getting water now they have someone that
runs with them to help them with their
pacing
not spotter right is that what it's
called i don't know
all right what do you got you yeah fans
help me out with that one
so i can come back next time and i don't
know fans that run marathon
okay so this is submitted by javi
underscore
naz on instagram ryan toy reviews he
made
30 million this year and during his
career
i do not know how long he's been on
youtube for
but he's brought in over 200 million
dollars
i wonder because he has revenue from his
toy
from his toy line hold up he has a toy
line he's his youtube
he has his own video games my son
subscribes to all of it
so the way it works so he'll get on
there and obviously like
he's only nine not now he's like 19 now
i don't know
he's older than nine now right no he's
nine i looked it up yesterday that's a
big ass nine-year-old he's a nightmare
but
my son can watch youtube once a week
either on saturday sunday picks for two
hours
but the thing is is he'll get on there
the toy companies will send him like the
new [ __ ]
and so he'll like play with him like
he'll show like on the video he's just
reviews
yeah now his parents can't touch his
money right well it's different because
youtube does follow the same type of
labor laws
that like uh hollywood yeah in hollywood
if you're under the age of 18
and you make money it goes into an
account that you can activate once you
become a legal adult
so no one else can touch it yeah it's
all your money
youtube with youtube there isn't really
like uh
a child labor laws let's think about it
too is when they set up the account so
when you set up a youtube account like
the money from finding kid
when i created it i had to give him a
bank account to fund the money into
so the kids when he started probably
four or five so his dad is the one who
set up all the bank account
so that money is just getting deposited
into this bank account you did that
oh
[Laughter]
so okay i guess that makes sense like
because i mean
youtube's not telling him what videos to
make they yeah he just makes it
so that's probably why they don't have
family started that channel when he was
really young
he was just like a kid unboxing stuff
and his parents would record him put it
on youtube
he got a huge following i think he
currently has 27 he's older than nine
bring it up how old is ron what's his
name because he he
had a show on nickelodeon too yeah he
sure did he's older
i'm nine
yeah go to images with makeup go tell
you well i saw him on
nickelodeon he looks like a like a third
i mean we can't tell which one's the
newest one you wanna just go to this
youtube channel right now oh my same
time wait until tiger's night tyre's
gonna look so much older than mine
hey why's he might just be one of those
kids why is that lady holding up
his parents are open the video oh this
she was uh she went to
jail for some sort of fraud or something
i forgot what it was
i don't know but yeah his parents have
said in videos before
that they set aside a lot of the money
so he can go to college and like he has
money college for him for
what if he wants to go to college he's
nine call you
mean the one month salary on youtube
would pay for college
the [ __ ] i'd be like call you and give
my [ __ ] money
you better buy me a house in the hidden
hills for him
just like set up don't worry we started
a college fund for ryan he's like
[ __ ] one video paid for college i know
right also i'm going to college for what
yeah communicate whatever he wants but
like you go to college the career yeah
but emma watson the actress from harry
potter she stopped acting because she
wanted to go to brown she wanted to
receive an education
there are actors like that i don't see
that i don't see that for ryan you don't
see that ryan's future
i mean i mean if my kid was making 60
million a year what the [ __ ] it i'd like
you
why i mean if you want to go to college
have fun you know yeah what if he wants
to do that
just be a regular experience yeah maybe
you know what's crazy about this is he
he still gets to be a kid yeah which is
cool you know what i mean like he
doesn't have to worry about like
fame yeah he's the most famous you're
not fame i'm talking about like uh
you know these kids like the acting
these shows yeah and they can't go to
regular they can't do
that they can't no you come home after
school and knock out one of these videos
like he's playing with toys like
what a kid does he's not on sale for
like 16 hours she's
like reviewing toys where can i buy his
merch
merch he has his own like mario kart uh
he's his own mario kart assertion
he has whole lines and uh what can i buy
his merch i saw his shirt
it looked pretty hard how much is this
yeah i like his heart sure yeah
let me see wow that was on target and
walmart
oh this guy's making buku money
they even talked about his uh merch line
they don't miss off youtube they don't
make it in adults
you can you said the article said that
youtube limits their advertising on kids
videos
youtube limits the advertising and kids
videos i think they're stricter with
what um is qualified as a
like kids content because before as long
as you checked a certain box and said
you were making content for kids they
let you have advertisements like
whatever
oh and now we're lying clean products
that generate more than 200 million
yeah almost drew it again god damn it
[ __ ] we gotta get on youtube his parents
like we're on youtube we're sending you
to college
not the same one yeah don't worry we're
gonna send you to college don't worry
your college paid for buddy
that's crazy good for good for them good
friend of his family
they live in texas yeah they live in
texas so not paying taxes either
oh he's getting all that money all that
money his parents are
his parents you just assume his parents
are shitty
yeah what if that yeah you don't know
you're pretty defensive with this kid
cat
you just like to [ __ ] on the parents i'm
not sure i don't i don't trust them not
uh
your choices parents i don't trust
parents though why
making 40 million dollars a year if you
were making that much money off of tiger
would you
take his money i wouldn't let tiger make
those videos i wouldn't put my kid i
wouldn't hormone it out like that
so already i i'm questioning their
ethics already
that's a fair you know how many videos
he has how many and then he's on
nickelodeon the dad's on nickelodeon
i'm just saying we've seen this story
how many times in hollywood it doesn't
end well that's a
that's a fair that's i think that's fair
was like dad can you set up the set so
we can crank out these videos
like if he wanted to i'm like i guess
but they're building an empire though
no it's working yeah all right
shout out to ryan man i don't know how
that story ends for him you know
hopefully well hopefully well yeah oh
yeah
he's doing great he's doing as good as
he can be i think
great's all relative my man
his parents still like all his money oh
yeah yeah that's when that law came
right
yeah yeah with like were your parents
kicked did britney spears get out her uh
no her dad owned uh and brittany
brittany started as a kid
yeah but i'm saying still to his date
yeah i think the
the court made some uh decision with
regarding the father
yeah he he he owns everything everything
powerful
you can't see her kids huh i don't know
what's going on no
how [ __ ] up is she i don't know we
don't know like what she's doing that's
the thing
like we know she's not doing great but
we don't know the severity of like
that that's the thing the law gave the
father power of turning in the kids and
the
things it must be really bad they're
they're just not gonna do what's crazy
is that like
people only know a surface level of the
story we just they just know based on
social media
so all these people think it's like oh
this is what it is like she's getting
[ __ ] over
like you know [ __ ] and naturally really
knows yeah you really know because i
heard she went crazy for a little bit
she did cut her hair but not she's not
normal even right now
i just it's hard to watch what she does
it's like she's just there like
like a vessel yeah but then everyone
around her is you know having her do
stuff
damn and that's how i ended for these
childhood actors
been in the game for a minute well
hopefully it works out for ryan though
yeah i hope so he's not a child actor
well he kind of is he has sean nicholson
yeah yeah it's like a certain extent he
is in that life
he's so famous i'm glad i moved to l.a
at 31 years old
i can't imagine being that i could not
imagine like being any younger than that
about the issues uh justin bieber has
yeah
he grew up in front of the camera he
seems good now yeah
because he found god i mean just saying
a [ __ ] song about how terrible his
childhood was
it's a great song lonely yeah that's
good oh really yeah the video is good
what does parents mean to him
didn't that guy don't think his parents
were his dad's kind of a piece of [ __ ]
really
that guy i think they had a weird
relationship because good guys
started starting uh his lonely video
shoot the little white guy looked just
like him
and good guys and good guys weird guys
well hopefully he was in room he was the
little boy in room
with uh brie larson how do you see wrong
oh it's so zoey's meal
uh i think you can get it on any like
streaming platform well bieber if you
need a homie to talk to man
she's one best friend she did yeah oh
she's a beast by the way and that's a
great actor i respect he was he was
i didn't i didn't realize he had a
[ __ ] up childhood i thought his
parents
his parents i believe got married and
had kids really
young they weren't really stable then he
kind of popped off and they
separated so it kind of affected him his
priority is getting famous
yeah good boys guys i'm sorry good boy
yeah
there's a lot he's a beast by the way
he's amazing he's a piece of an actor
but you're going to hate on justin
timberlake
yeah because he's a beast of an actor
but the voice is good oh yeah he's in
good boys
yes that's what i'm saying good boys and
he was in doctor sleep by the way movie
wasn't that bad
he's gonna hate on jt all right him on
in room though
so good i'm at the washington what else
you get all right
here okay so i guess the last
few weeks tick tock has been doing this
sweep
on their platform where any creator that
has their only fans
linked in their bio has been their
account has either been suspended
or deleted but then you see a
discrepancy with
the people who are having their accounts
taken out because
bigger creators like bella thorne she's
on tick tock now she has a link to her
only fans but her account is still
there so it seems like they're only
getting rid of accounts with
and only fans link if you're a smaller
creator who
isn't bringing as much revenue they're
kind of like picking and choosing who
gets to have their only fans link
up and a lot of people have been
appealing because a lot of these sex
workers are
like on tick tock very clean but just
happen to have their only fans linked
and tick tock has said that it's because
they want to minimize the amount of
people
logging off of their app but they're
only picking and choosing certain ones
weird cause like uh the bigger creators
tana mojo
uh jake paul's fake wife or whatever she
still has her tick tock up and has her
only fans link
weird mia khalifa i think still does as
well but here's the thing
all these are privately owned companies
it's like they can do where the [ __ ]
they want
huh so wait if you have an only fans you
can't be on tick tock
uh they suspended your account for a
while because they say that your
account has somehow breached the like
sexuality and like nudity rule
but then on the app there are also a lot
of very underage girls dancing very
skimpy outfits
i know that's what i was just getting
ready to stay that's why a lot of people
criticize because a lot of those younger
girls doing those dances
are the bigger uh people on that
platform and so they get to keep
their videos up because that's what the
kids are coming to see
so it's almost like they're picking and
choosing who they get to take down and
they're just complaining about that
these damn corporate scum mm-hmm
wow that's very punk of you it is like
you're [ __ ] me i think about it all
the time right
these are [ __ ] people hopefully they
can
come on instagram though
and this i just thought it was cool i
was listening to bill burr
and bert's podcast yesterday and they
mentioned that action bronson
had lost a lot of weight because he got
to weightlifting and look at him he
looks great now
dude he lost how much did he lose he
says 248 pounds 8
pounds down from 375. i am damn he was
so
wow he was big he was big
but he looks great now this is the
inspiration you guys needed i'm rooting
for him
i'm ready for action bronson can you see
is he still going to shoot that show uh
it's [ __ ] delicious
oh yeah i think so yeah because he lost
something well yeah
he was so big oh my gosh
looking like non keto epilito man look
at him god damn
go that one up is that a no that has to
be the top right that's fake no no
i think that's someone else someone else
that's not actually bronte oh gotcha i
was about to say
dude props to him shut up damn he was
so good for him i'm so happy
health is cool did you have something or
no
are they gonna show us something didn't
you say you're gonna show us something
you want you want our like natural
reactions oh you're doing it
for wednesday today no no no wednesday
you know i think we should play that
we're gonna have a listening party yeah
yeah
good for him though for him i know right
i love stuff like that
i believe in y'all i think y'all can go
down if y'all just dedicate
we're not action bronson big brother
well i mean
we're not at like a
[Applause]
we joke around being thick
it's all fun and games okay that's not
inspiration i guess severely out of
shape
i'm very fat i'm thick i'm not fat all
right
all right all right stick with three c's
all right i'm sure you guys have seen
this video by now
a hospital worker i haven't seen it
texas was supposed to be given on-air a
kobe 19 vaccine shot
and then if you look at it the there's
like the thing was already depressed the
syringe is already depressed and he just
touches like that
and he takes it out yeah so i'll just
show you the video put in his arm i was
like you know
oh yeah yep already down watch you see
him doing that
[Music]
nothing i was on twitter matt is here
you want to look at it one more time uh
so all right so what are we saying that
the vaccines that people don't want to
fake people don't want to take it
brendan
but i don't understand what happened oh
that needle oh
so they never really inserted anything
into him nothing they just act well they
just
they have to do this they didn't want to
waste it on that guy you know
so see that little that gasket that
rubber gasket yeah it's already already
depressed it's all the way down
so they're not actually injecting things
and these don't
did they not think people were gonna see
that [ __ ] dude and on top of it they
they
didn't double down but they're saying
like oh yeah well he did get some of it
and then we finished it later on
when it's obvious stop lying to people
yeah
they're all lying wow yeah
it's just see they're right there yes
the umc admitted one of its workers
didn't receive the entire vaccine and
that a second shot was administered to
to erase any doubt
[Music]
but so they issued it to five nurses
four out of the five got it and this guy
just kind of sketched sketchy with it i
guess i don't know it was just
maybe it could be them all freaking out
and you know there's cameras
everyone's watching so maybe the guy
just didn't put the vaccine in i don't
know but for them to say that he got
some of it and they got the rest later
is also weird
i mean yeah bro we trash
we trash for for the longest it was like
we need a vaccine we need a vaccine now
everyone's like it's fake
just shut the [ __ ] up
nothing's easy no nothing nothing
trash oh bro we can't just
never satisfy it we're never satisfied
you're right i like that
we trash oh man okay
do you guys ever uh watch that show on i
think i was on abc fresh off the boat
oh i love that show thank you really
yeah oh my god that was
that was your version of blackish right
i mean i never seen either no
no no that's not completely black but it
was it was dope it's based off of your
guy eddie wong is that you like
oh yeah it's based off his life he was
like the executive producer or something
but then they changed it entirely so it
was pissed off
anyways wait the child name is eddie
though the black
man yeah so it's based off his life
it's like his memoir but they changed it
up a lot once once they got to the
network of course they changed it
yeah so this guy one of the stars he be
he's now
entering into harvard he's huge did you
know that he's like damn near six feet
yeah if not six feet right yeah
he got really big for a while and he
looked like oh you lost michael henney
and uh what's the philadelphia show it's
always sunny philadelphia he played
uh a character on that and then him and
malcolm actually looked alike yeah
really let me see this chin yeah okay
his mom's filming this and so this kid's
an actor he just
got accepted to harvard
[Applause]
the committee uh has admitted you to the
harvard class of 2025
oh how old is he
17 i think wait 20 25. some four years
yeah he's hit early program too i guess
he's super smart
he's smart though my mom's crying oh my
god mom
gotta go to ball that's cool
who's that in the bed with a shirt
brother
good for him god that's like
asian parents that's winning the lotto
the harvard
i'm so proud and so happy and so
this would be the number one gift that i
could ever give my parents
oh really yeah it's like this or
becoming a doctor a doctor
sucks in the winter though okay but to
go to harvard would be
insane mm-hmm that's crazy good for her
i was a big fan of fresh off the boat
you heard a theme song
never i never saw wait it's not showing
doesn't cameron do it
uh i think it's gonna be another season
remember it made news because the girl
was like oh man it's going to go on
again she wanted to do other things
the main woman the star kills it by the
way
you know she didn't want to sign on
again but then when he got renewed she
got pissed off and people went off on
her
because she was like you just got
renewed for a hit show because she
wanted she want to do her own thing yeah
do you want her
she said that she got another project
lined up if it didn't
could that uh show didn't continue so
she was just bummed out that she
couldn't do another she bet
because that was like right after uh
crazy rich asians so like rose kind of
started pouring in
yeah she was the main girl in crazier
she got crazy
it's any sort of like kind of rom-com
it's good i mean if you want to see
wrong conversation
she's in that stripper movie yeah she's
also in hustlers
that's her on that strip what's that
girl name jlo
what's that girl what's that what's that
what that girl name she dances and [ __ ]
kiki palmer that's my girl bro oh yeah
keith palmer is amazing i love kiki
another child star did you did you see
that
uh i was on social media that the the
kid whose dad passed away from cancer
and the kid turned 21 and he didn't know
it but the dad left
the the sister and the mom ten dollars
so the kid
could buy his first bear he's like i
won't be there but here's ten dollars
for you all right
first bear bear bear b-e-e-r
oh you haven't seen that chin no that's
sad that [ __ ] up that's pretty cool
though
mm-hmm cause the dad was like i can't be
there but i want you to buy your first
beer is this
and then budweiser sent him a whole
[ __ ] like a hundred thousand beers or
something that's sweet
what the guy don't even drink um pass
away from cancer uh just dad leaves uh
no son ten dollars dude oh there there
it is where
this one yeah from indian express
how old is the kid i'm just just turning
twin oh i'm i'm asking because
you say he left him all right
yeah i played the reservation almost six
years ago before my dad passed he gave
my sister this 10
bill to give me on my 21st birthday
birthday so he could buy me my first
beer cheers pop
that's so sweet and then scroll down
chin uh-huh
oh they're from canada and then uh
and eiser bush sent him like a [ __ ] ton
of beer
yeah no this just means i'm gonna
that's pretty cool right i just don't
know that's so sweet and very sad
where did you read this from uh it's on
my newsfeed oh
i don't have twitter all right
someone kept tagging us in this and i
don't know i don't know who it was but
then
it just shows this incredibly thick bear
oh [ __ ] oh
wow that's the action bronson of beers
is this one no is that real that's fake
i mean that's so big
oh my god it looks exhausting
or it might be pregnant it could be a
female pregnant oh but even so that is
just
gigantic that bear's severely fake yo
that bear's gonna get eaten alive
exactly
i mean it's just so chunky
and round yeah that'd be super it almost
does like
you want to like like i don't know
because
thank you that's not saying a question
like it'd be tough in nature to get that
fat that's what i'm saying
humans are leaving like crazy food every
night thank you this is like you live
next to a neighborhood
yeah like yeah sure it's garbage yeah
how can they fake this though
because i know i don't think it's fake i
i don't know i don't know how a bear
could get that big not in another way
no way i've never seen anything like
this no
you said it might be pregnant but even
the pregnancy is yeah
so thick wait big bears do exist well
they get real
fat for the winter because they're not
they go hybrid nation yeah but
damn look at that insane this one looks
adorable yeah oh like a regular bear
dude those things will eat
you
beers are [ __ ] scary scary they're
going to montana
you ever seen any uh grizzly bears
around there that went not once
they said there's been a few brown
waiters whoa
that ain't real oh dog how about me my
girl take the family to hell and raise
and we went like
to pasadena college to eat it on the
lawn and i was sitting
i had these these short pair of god
shorts on these short shorts
and i was like eating my stairs like
this my girl goes your nuts are hanging
out
i said you know what's sad is i can't
touch him because i get howland ray's
sauce
with my hand so i said my nuts just
gonna be out
you didn't want to put your leg down
you're just no yeah you just doing it i
was just like
post it up my nuts are hanging out
didn't you feel a breeze
dude that reminds me there's this uh
this guy this guy's house
burned down in colorado
you know this guy lost his home right
and he has these kids and he's on the
front
door he's on the front page of the
denver post which
is like rla times like it's it's like
the new york post
denver post is the big mags in denver
and he's all sad he's like
all he has left is like this little like
you know like this bag
and he's like they're like it's like
despire times you know like this poor
guy
and no one noticed this and they take a
picture and his house is burnt down
behind him he's like
all sad but he has cut off jean shorts
and on the front covers the newspaper
his nuts are hanging out the side of his
jeans
can we bring that
was that a big deal oh it was the
biggest deal
they had to pull all the newspapers are
you it's so funny yeah i think you sued
them
hopefully you bought a house with the
money i hope so
testicles hang out right yeah
that's because it's gonna be a weird
conspiracy nuts
different post photographer oh no i mean
we can look for it just
please let this be still around me you
know uh yeah if we just gotta google the
right thing
uh uh denver post for sure uh pretty
sure
you're either that or rocky mountain
news i'll do colorado just do
colorado newspaper man's testicles hangs
out yeah
there's like not that many options here
okay
it won't even let you look at it what
about jay
it was a home fire right it's a home
fire he lost everything
he's got a front cover but he sued the
newspaper
yeah he got money so he got a new house
maybe
maybe so if anyone out there can find it
please send it to us oh yeah
i don't want to see it now yeah he said
the kids was in the front
it's so funny nuts are just hanging i
mean you're talking about front page of
the in when newspapers are newspapers
it's like in the 90s just he's all sad
the front is nuts
how did nobody notice that someone just
missed it
there's a lot of somebody having like a
gray system of humor like you know what
you know he's probably up midnight it
was like finally submitted
like sand dude
and his nuts
type in uh uh front page of newspaper
man's uh
nut their hat we have to find it
you want to put nuts really let's just
put them in the balls balls
balls let's do nuts first there it is
that sure was my this is the actual guy
in his rocky mountain wait he's on what
is he there this is like a forum yeah
but this is him coming out i wonder if
they have the actual it says maybe too
old to be available the image oh that
sucks well let me google this sure was
my test
on the front page of rocky that sure was
let's do this oh there it goes oh
man that's okay we're going to go back
look anybody remember this unfortunate
guy this story was nuts
is it out there i don't know that's
right maybe they have a
link to the story yes
there you go yeah oh you can't see it
though i
see it that's a bad picture look at it
right there though
no you you can see it like it there it's
blurry but he's not you can
that's his that's all it's all that's
his favorites
18 years ago rocky mountain news
this shitty scan doesn't do that ball
just yeah
i'm telling you isn't it it's clear as
day is nuts
yeah oh [ __ ] you're close
like look at him sitting on the thing
let's get the cabinet hey steer off that
way into the sunset yeah no doubt
no doubt
nuts are hanging
it was a big deal in colorado man shall
someone i'm sure someone got fired his
name name was
fred flute can anyone see this name it's
so blurry right over here fred finn
little no not a would be is that tank
it's too blurry yeah it's too blurry
[ __ ] all right well we know
it's the rocky mountain that's funny
it's so crazy yup
how big was this house it's just a
regular house in the ashes
down but not out
like the guy got fired what if he wanted
to quit he was like you know
great yeah i'm gonna go out like balls
out i'm just gonna do it
damn all of his boots and [ __ ]
just lost his whole heart
just when he didn't think things get any
worse yeah
well let me try one more thing june 24th
2002
no nevermind man how can we someone's
going to send us a good picture though
yeah
if you type in rocky mountain news uh
man's nuts
i don't know right ridiculous you gotta
get a good picture man
man's nuts hanging out
no only that same one
what what if okay okay okay
the rocky mountain news rest in peace
yeah there's somebody's cousin right
here let's see
yeah there we go let's go oh man it's
too dark
yeah still you can see his nut hanging
out there you can see a little bit but
yeah it's clear he's dead on his thigh
yeah who's that guy
it's stuck on his thigh like a bat wing
it's cool who's that guy
that's hilarious isn't that funny this
is so [ __ ] funny
all right what else you got jen what
this is someone's gonna send us a pic
cool um this is from our boy justin wren
this is his instagram so it's some some
neighbor guy
was choking on steak and then he went to
his other neighbor who was a female
woman and then she was able to get the
steak unlodged
[Music]
why would you knock on the door you're
panicking
oh he's choking yeah he's joking
look at that look how long it takes too
yo what the where is she at
huh
look at her
oh get your back into it girl
he knows that ambulance was gonna be
expensive
that was weird how scared he was you
called 9-1-1 yeah look how much she
jumped into action she was like boom
boom boom right away
is easy to choke on yeah for me it's
rice
is that a cuz how much rice is that
down in rice and then if i like swallow
too much you can feel it right here oh
damn i'm close to choking dogs
you can swallow water but if it doesn't
go all the way through you can feel the
water just chilling there
you're all damn it's thick down there
i've never choked on i've never heard
about
the rice i've never choked on rice i'm
choking a [ __ ] piece of steak i tell
you that much what you choked on
uh not rice or steak what did you
it was
i didn't know he was gonna be that
savage cat i was like but when i eat
fish sometimes if you swallow a bone it
gets stuck right here
horrible yeah oh that's like you know
especially salmon i'm like yeah salmon
catfish
yeah what about you who else we choking
on stuff long
yeah right who else what the [ __ ] are
we found out a lot today okay one more
yeah yeah
all right so we was trying to follow big
things
what i don't know what this is exactly
but this is oldies for life
and then uh i just saw this on my own so
it's like this is an instagram account
for life underscore but i mean i so i
thought it was old people
but i guess it's oldies like jam
so i can't really play the music but
this is an old dude break dancing and
check out check out how good he is
oh i've seen this this dope oh he kills
it look at the rope
this is leonardo dicaprio like 20 years
for walsh i love it
wait he could break dance oh he killed
him he used to be a breakdancer when he
was younger did you see wolf of the
wolf good movie i don't like how
everybody's not
freaking out i don't know they just like
going big [ __ ] just like whatever larry
i know right yeah he probably do this
every time like okay he's showing up
yeah he might have
you know just doing this all the time
he's smooth as [ __ ] yeah he's killing
him and he's tall too let's run into
that
rope oh
get them on the podcast i i'll show them
a little bit yeah that was dope
all right man is that it chin that's it
all right dude you have to take call i
thought you got to harvard
[Laughter]
see what you did there
didn't stop everything i didn't have to
take it but we were second
we were just talking no way
no phony's off i'm getting a couch
delivered
oh yeah thank you yes this cat this uh
crew will be in west palm beach all
shows are almost sold out palm beach
florida get your tan asses there
um just general admission is left vip is
sold out
that is december 31st through january
2nd
and then this crew will also be in texas
two shows on friday two shows on
saturday there's january 29th through
the 30th
san marcos texas right outside austin
right outside san antonio
kind of in the middle there san marcos
texas get your minds right
that show will sell out we have a very
special guest there as well
that is san marcos texas january 29th
through 30th
tfatkay.com for tickets thick boy smiley
gear just dropped
get it while it's hot good big boy
smiley hoodies
tees hats we got it all there the hoodie
i'm wearing right now is available
t-shirts sweats we have thick boys
sweats there as well
and we restocked the tie-dye and the
short sleeve hoodies as well
and the hats thickboy.com is that it
fellas
yeah dope we out